so i just watched the new movie run with
our queen
sarah paulson which ironically doesn't
have any running in it now you've
probably seen my title and maybe are
like
hey thanks story i actually like that
movie i mean look it's got a 94 to 80
critic to audience score on rotten
tomatoes a
64 if you go over to metacritic so
before you go automatically disliking
this video
hear me out this movie is pretty fun i'd
even say
it might be a slightly above average
thriller but as i was watching this and
the mystery of the film started to
unravel i was like
why did they do that why did they make
that decision so
get in your wheelchairs everybody pour
yourself some delicious paint thinner
because here's why run doesn't make any
sense it's interesting to note that run
was originally scheduled to come out in
theaters remember those but due to
something called
hold on let me check my notes here
coronavirus it was picked up by hulu and
it was probably a smart move too
they knew this movie wouldn't be getting
any oscar noms like another wheelchair
movie we know
or that it would be breaking any box
office records
[Music]
what am i looking at and considering the
success original films like palm springs
have been for the platform hulu was
looking for another win also before we
get started huge shout out to kira allen
this was her first feature and i thought
she did an incredible job
hollywood actually did something right
this time and cast an actual wheelchair
user in the title role
by the way have you guys been following
that matty ziegler sia autism
controversy
if this video gets a million likes i'll
do a video on it anyway the film is
basically about a mother who keeps her
daughter sick so that she can be with
her forever
and hulu literally came out with a show
like that earlier in the year called the
act and you know there's gotta be some
hulu executive who is like constantly
pitching mother-daughter poison stories
anyway the movie plays out like a
traditional thriller as chloe the film's
protagonist
slowly finds out what her mother is
doing writers anisse chaganti and sev
o'hannian clearly know about screenplay
structure and i just have to note that
sevohanian is currently writing the new
space jam movie
roughly 10 minutes into the film we get
its inciting incident you know that
event that kicks the movie's ass to get
it going here chloe finds a prescription
bottle of her medication
but mysteriously it's prescribed to her
mother
now i know this is a minor gripe i'll
get into the bigger criticisms in a bit
but when
diane chloe's mother is eventually
confronted about the label she says
oh that's just the receipt on the side
of the bottle which if you've been
taking medication your entire life
there's no way chloe would buy that
excuse
okay minor gripe over here's where
things start to get unbelievable while
diane is out gardening chloe decides to
call the pharmacy to find out what this
drug trigoxin does and she somehow knows
the telephone number of the pharmacy off
by heart but doesn't know what the label
on the side of a prescription bottle
does
anyway the previous night she tried to
figure out what trigoxin was
online but the internet was conveniently
down you'll find there are a lot of
conveniences in this movie like the fact
chloe doesn't own a phone so she can
never call for help or even though diane
eventually locks her daughter in her own
room she cuts the phone line and power
to
the wheelchair elevator thing as if she
somehow knew her daughter would escape
when she isn't able to get an answer
from the pharmacy
this is where things get even more
far-fetched first she dials a random
number
i don't have internet second someone
actually picks up
how many times do i have to tell you to
take my number off no
and third she's able to get this
stranger to go onto his computer and
search drugs for him
i don't have internet or a cell phone
and i need your help with a very urgent
google search
now i don't know about you guys but when
a stranger calls my house asking me to
search for drugs i obviously do it
wanting more answers chloe devises a new
scheme
taking her mother out to the movies and
pretending to go to the washroom but
then
bolting to the pharmacy across the
street to ask what the hell these pills
are for
sorry everyone cutting through i'm
paralyzed feel bad for me bonus points
if you notice the name of the film
they're seeing is breka which is kind of
fun because she's trying to break out
for most of the movie
turns out the pills were prescribed by a
veterinarian as a muscle relaxant for a
dog they don't even own
but diane has been giving them to her
daughter making it so she can't walk but
then i'm like how did the mom get a
prescription for an animal narcotic when
they don't
have a dog our vets allowed to give out
narcotics without actually seeing the
patient
i don't know so anyway chloe has an
asthma attack and wakes up
locked in her room then there's this
weird scene where diane takes a shower
and she has all these scars over her
back and we're like oh
how did she get those scars we'll
probably find out later but nope they're
never brought up again there's also
another scene where diane writes an
email to chloe's doctor about how her
new medication
is giving her delusions then i'm like
why are you writing to your
doctor when you know that she's not
delusional at all you know you've been
giving her dog
drugs anyway diane has to run some
errands and chloe devises an elaborate
plan to break out of her room
chloe is good with engineering stuff so
hold on let me take a big gasp of air
here she fills her mouth with water
takes a bunch of extension cord climbs
out her window over to her mother's
window uses some sort of engineering
heater thing to crack the glass
then spits the cold water on the hot
spot to smash it open
not gonna lie i thought this was really
ingenuitive and i haven't seen it done
in other movies but at the same time i'm
like
why didn't she just break the glass why
did she go through all this trouble when
she could have just
smashed it open anyway chloe is able to
escape a flag down the mailman but it
just so happens her mom conveniently
arrives at the same time ultimately
knocking him out with a syringe she
always seems to have on hand oh yeah she
later kills him diane ends up chaining
chloe in her wheelchair in the basement
where she's conveniently left out a
whole bunch of stuff she'd never want
chloe to see
in plain sight and a lot of it just
doesn't make any sense
for example chloe has been anxiously
awaiting on acceptance letters from
various colleges
instead of the mom disposing them she
puts them in plain sight in the basement
there's also this shoe box right in the
open next to the tv
that contains all these damning
documents that prove
chloe isn't diane's child and that diane
stole her from another couple years ago
when her
own daughter died and i'm not really
sure why she go through the effort of
clipping out a newspaper article of this
it just doesn't make sense to me so
diane comes downstairs shocked that
chloe has found all these things and i'm
like dude
you're the one who left her down here
with this stuff and i kid you not she
makes a syringe cocktail out of paint
thinner
no i'm no nurse ratchet you put that in
her she's gonna die
and that's not what diane wants she just
wants to keep her daughter forever and
ever so chloe knowing her death is
imminent
chugs a bottle of poisonous
organophosphate like you do
in the hopes her mom will call to get
her to the hospital and that's exactly
what happens as we venture into the
final act of the film
chloe can't speak anymore because of her
poison chug so she has to tell the nurse
what happened via crayon
at this point they think she's suicidal
so no sharp objects like pens for her
and diane knowing any second she could
be caught whisks chloe away when all the
other doctors and nurses are busy with a
code blue now it looks like diane is
gonna get away with it until she's
stopped by a set of stairs not being
wheelchair accessible
oh the irony and we could get into a
whole discussion about how living with a
disability is like having a murderous
overbearing mother who limits what you
can do
but that's an idea for a different video
with nowhere to go diane is
shot by the armed hospital guards i'm
from canada so our hospital security
guards are only armed with maple syrup
flavored pepper spray
so this was a shock to me and here is
where i want to talk about some changes
that could have improved this movie and
where you write in the comments about
how wrong i am in the real version diane
falls after being shot and we see her at
the bottom of the stairs then fast
forward seven years where chloe visits
her in the infirmary at the department
of corrections she can kind of walk now
too
i think the movie missed an awesome
ironic ending if it were to be revealed
that it's now
diane in a wheelchair her bones having
been shattered after falling down
all those stairs like it would have been
awesome for chloe to wheel diane around
their roles having been reversed
instead we get this zany stinger ending
where chloe's been hiding these green
pills in her mouth like maybe even her
stomach and she tells her mother to open
wide well that's the ending i also think
the way the movie started wasn't that
great either the opening scene is sarah
paulson going into labor hinting that
she's gonna lose her child if it were me
i'd cut all that out because
viewers are smart enough to realize
something's up and that chloe probably
isn't her real baby this also takes away
precious screen time that could have
been devoted to making us care about the
protagonist and here i think the writers
did a disservice by making us
sympathize with chloe but not empathize
and that's a key distinction for example
the beginning montage where we're
introduced to chloe shows us how
difficult her life is
she can't walk has rashes all over her
body has to take a bunch of pills and
daily blood tests to make sure her
diabetes is in check
just because someone has ailments or a
doesn't automatically make us
care about the character if it were that
easy writers would make
every character in a movie they'd want
us to care about have some sort of
disability what's missing here
is empathy and the greatest way to
create empathy is through
shared pain i know that sounds a bit
weird but hear me out
if i were writing this beginning instead
of diane hiding chloe's acceptance
letters
i'd have diane come in so excited that a
letter from her number one university
just came in chloe and diane would be so
excited to see the decision only for it
to be shattered when chloe is met with a
big fat rejection
halfway through the movie we'd then
reveal that her mother made this
rejection letter herself it would also
explain why her mother has her own
laptop which is never really brought up
what i like about this is that her
rejection is tied to chloe's want
to get into college and be her own
independent person
and this rejection shatters that
creating empathy how many times in our
life have we wanted something so badly
and not had it happen that's the
difference between empathy and sympathy
i can't relate to being in a wheelchair
but i can relate to that feeling of
rejection
if you want to learn more about this i
did a whole video on the difference
between
sympathy and empathy and horror films
but be kind it was the first youtube
video i
ever made caring about your main
character is so important if you don't
care about him or her then what's the
point
when you do care it heightens the
thrills significantly something very
important in a thriller now look i was
pretty harsh on run but overall it's a
totally fun ride where you can just turn
off your brain and enjoy the run
okay bad pun if you've got nothing to do
on a sunday afternoon
definitely check it out thanks for
watching everyone if you want to help me
out in the channel be sure to like
subscribe and comment what you thought
of the movie below
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much